موجز الاخبار من الجزيره السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله دعاء وزراوي خارجيه الدول
البلطيق الثلاثي استونيا واليتوانيا
ولاتفيا دعوه المانيا لتقديم دبابات الى
اوكرانيا فورا وكان حلفاء اوكرانيا قد
فشلوا في الاتفاقيه على تسليم الدبابات
ثقيله خلال اجتماعهم في قاعده اينشتاين
بالمانيا الجمعه وتركز الخلافه على
دبابات قتاليه المانيه الصنع
من جانبه دعم مستشار رئاسه الاوكرانيه
اوكرانيا ما يلزمها من السلاح باسرع وقت
ممكن وقال بدل يكفي تغريده ان التردد
العالميه في تسليم اوكرانيا للاسلحه يقتل
مزيدا من الاوكرانيين
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اجراء واحداث
الدفاع الجوي تدريبات في مقاطعه موسكو
تحاكي صدها هجمات على منشات عسكريه
وصناعيه واداريه وعشره الوزاره لان
التدريبات شارك فيها اكثر من مئه وخمسين
عسكريا و30 وحده من الاليات العسكريه
الخاصه
سياسيه وحقوقيه تونسيه بالاحكام العسكريه
الصادره بحق رئيس الائتلاف الكرامه وخمسه
من نواب الاعتراف بالبرلمان المنحل من
جانبه دعى رئيس حركه النهضه راشد الغنوشي
الى جراه حوار وطنيا لتحقيق التوافق
والتعايش هناك
وكنت لف الكرامه هي المعارض في تونس قد
اعلن اعتقال الشرطه رئيس كتلته النيابيه
في البرلمان المنحل سيف الدين مخلوف ودعا
الى مؤمن وصفهم بالشركاء الفاعلين الى
الالتفاف حول رؤيه وطنيه موحده بهدف اسقاط
ما وصفه بالانقلاب
في المقابل دعا الرئيس التونسي وقيس سعيد
الى ضروره التصدي لكل المفسدين ممن
يعتقدون انهم فوق القانون
طلبه الحكومه في بوركينا فاسو فرنسا بشكل
رسمي سحب قوتها من البلاد في غضون شهر
واحد ياتي ذلك بعد مظاهرات منظمه منذ عده
اشهر للمطالبه برحيل الجنود الفرنسيه
القياده الامريكيه في افريقيا افريقيه
شماليه العاصمه الصوماليه
من حركه الشباب وفدا بيان للقياده
الامريكيه ان الغرت وقعت بين مكان الجيش
الصومالي يخوض قتالا عنيفا بالقرب من بلده
ضد مصلحي الحركه
قال محمد الرئيس الامريكي
اضافيه
عضويه ايضا في مجلس الشيوخ واخرى عندما
كان نائبا الرئيس
انه بعيدا وفريقه القانونيه الشخصي ياخذون
الامر بمسؤوليه ويعملون على ضمان حصول
وزاره العدل والمحقق الخاص على كل ما
يحتاجونه
اينما كنتم قبل اوقاتكم بكل خير